[Music]
tea is the most popular drink in the
world and there are countless ways we
make and consume it but if you want to
drink tea in the oldest way we still
know of you'll first need to hike deep
into the remote team ount ins of
Southwest China and handpick leads and
buds from tea trees that are hundreds of
years old it's a long way to go for
authentic Chinese tea but one person is
doing it
[Music]
my name is Shannon tang I'm the owner of
tea trunk which is a tea house in New
York City we specialize in historic
Chinese tea historic he's really
representing a pinnacle of tea culture
and these teas are usually not
mass-produced and they trying to be as
authentic to the tea as possible it's
almost like a masterpiece of music
played versus a practice or a original
piece of artwork or versus the copies
the masterpiece tea so to speak comes
from ancient tea trees that grow in the
wild the only bud for 15 days out of the
year so Shannon must race each spring to
find the trees and harvest them in time
with the help of local farmers the best
tea trees are always on some of the
hardest to get to places because they
need to be on very steep slopes we
usually motorcycle a little bit
sometimes we cut water sometimes we
climb in this region it's not uncommon
for two trees to grow for several
hundred years these tea trees right now
is at its prime and this is what he is
meant to taste like hmm once we pick the
key we need to spread it out in a whole
area where the water can travel out
before we can walk fry the key this step
is to kill the enzyme so the keys
allocation can be stopped
then we take the tea leaves out and then
we wrote the key once the Sun dry the
tea you need to pick out any
discoloration this sorting process
usually takes months to finish because
we do have to do them one by one with
every single tea months will go by
before this tea is ready to be poured
out but the journey is well worth it to
Chinon those extreme fine points in
haste that he offers us I think it
provides us a level of joy that's beyond
anything else and my job here is to
preserve this art and hopefully even
push it to a new height
[Music]
you